fallait s'y attendre j'ai fait une vidéo
sur l'iphone 13 pro et c'est totalement
partie
[Musique]
et salue les gens derrière l'écran c'est
françois pour la gêne équipements encore
je suis ravi de vous retrouver une
nouvelle fois sur cette chaîne et si
vous êtes nouveau mais ici on parle de
faire des vidéos on parle de montage de
tournage de matos donc si c'est quelque
chose qui vous intéresse n'hésitez pas à
cliquer sur le petit bouton s'abonner
qui se situe juste en dessous il ya
sûrement des choses qui vont vous
intéresser alors aujourd'hui c'est story
times sur un sujet qui pourrait paraître
bat pas forcément en rapport avec la
chaîne et pourtant vous allez voir qu'il
l'est complètement je vous parlais d'une
vidéo que j'ai fait sur tik tok sur une
des fonctionnalités de l'iphone 13
proulx que je trouve très intéressante
et surtout de comment c'est parti
totalement en cacahuète parce que les
gens comprennent pas certaines choses et
je me suis dit que ça valait le coup
d'expliquer certains points parce que
cette fonctionnalité elle soulève mais
des questions est ce qu'on va dire dans
cette vidéo ça va vous aider à discerner
les éléments marketing des éléments
vraiment intéressant quand on parle de
ce payx de caméras que ce soit du
smartphone ou des hybrides c'est un peu
le même concept alors je préviens aussi
d'entrer je vais faire des raccourcis je
vais pas rentrer dans les détails hyper
technique sinon la vidéo ferait une
heure ça serait totalement indigeste
mais l'idée c'est de vous permettre de
mieux comprendre les choses pour faire
les bons choix est évidemment je ne suis
pas en train de dire qu'il faut
absolument acheter un iphone 13 pro je
ne suis pas en train de dire non plus
que ça va remplacer les caméras les
hybrides tout ça juste il ya vraiment
cette fonctionnalité qui je pense est un
game challenger pour tous qui va toucher
à la vidéo dans les années voire les
mois à venir rentrons donc dans le vif
du sujet cette fonctionnalité dont j'ai
parlé dans cette vidéo tik tok c'est la
possibilité avec l'iphone 13 pro
d'enregistrer en interne avec un codec
qui s'appelle le prores 4 2 2 10 bits
non c'est pas un gros mot et oui pour
moi c'est quelque chose de très très
très très très très très très très très
très intéressant même si cette
fonctionnalité sur un smartphone ça va
intéresser très peu de gens mais ça
n'empêche pas que selon moi ça changera
beaucoup de choses pour la suite
l'iphone 13 pro permet donc
d'enregistrer en proa skate 2 10 bits
dans la limite de 4 à 60 images par
seconde et quand j'ai posté ma vidéo
parmi les commentaires il ya cette
remarque qui revenue à énormément oui
mais mon xiaomi où mon samsung qui fait
de l'amica et je vois pas en quoi c'est
nouveau ça reste de la 4k 60fps argument
totalement con et je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi on va reprendre les bases un
petit peu qu'est ce que c'est la 4k et
l'a8 cas et bien tout simplement c'est
ce qu'on appelle la résolution
c'est-à-dire pour faire simple la taille
de votre image par exemple ici je filme
en cas de cas si je filmer en full hd et
que je voulais comparé la taille d'image
s'adonneraient à peu près ça et donc
forcément vous voyez que l'image est
beaucoup plus petit par conséquent si on
filme en full hd et qu'on veut afficher
l'image sur un écran 4 cas il va falloir
les tirer et ben c'est comme un jpeg
forcément on est si on zoome on perd en
détail c'est moins net c'est moins
défini il ya moins de pixels dans
l'image donc on peut pas aller aussi
loin mais d'un autre côté ça va se voir
sur un grand écran de cette vidéo et
tournant en 4k je vous encourage à la
passer sur youtube en 1080 et si vous la
regardez sur un smartphone vous verrez
peut-être une petite différence mais pas
forcément quelque chose d'énorme
c'est la même chose pour la 4k et labica
ça dépend aussi de la taille de l'écran
sur laquelle vous le regardez si vous
regardez sur un tout petit écran
forcément vous verrez moins de détails
par contre si vous regarder sur un écran
gigantesque ça vous sautera aux yeux
évidemment et on est d'accord que les
écrans rica pour l'instant ça court pas
les rues donc même si l'écran est grand
la différence sera pas forcément énorme
l'avicca par contre ça a des avantages
notamment le fait que ben il ya plus de
pixels donc techniquement on devrait
avoir plus d'information plus de
définition dans l'image même si on l'a
d'armes scale si on la réduit en 4k un
autre avantage de l'avicca c'est qu'on
va pouvoir aussi joué dans l'image sans
dégradation et ça c'est très pratique
parce qu'en gros on va pouvoir filmer un
plan est à voir dans ce plan en jouant
plusieurs valeurs de plans alors c'est
artificiel et s'est pas totalement juste
mais ça peut quand même donné un petit
peu plus de vie un plan sans forcément
dégradé puisqu'on va zoomer de dans la
forcément on a de la bic a donc on peut
aller zoom est bien bien bien avant de
se rendre compte que bah c'est juste un
crop la résolution oui c'est important
c'est sûr mais le codex et au moins tout
aussi importante la résolution
finalement c'est juste la taille de
l'image mais c'est pas parce qu'on va
avoir de l'avicca qu'on va avoir une
belle image ça ça va dépendre de plein
d'autres choses notamment du code écrit
c'est là qu'on va parler du progress
pour faire simple votre caméra soit un
smartphone ou un hybride elle va capter
des informations et les retranscrire
sous forme numérique quand on utilise
des fichiers raw par exemple des
fichiers bruts l'euro n'est pas une
image l'euro c'est juste des
informations qui vont être traités
ensuite par un ordinateur un téléphone
ou la caméra pour pouvoir être visible
en gros pour pouvoir visualiser ces
informations qui sont captés par le
capteur de la caméra il va y avoir un
travail d'interprétation de la caméra de
l'ordinateur pour pouvoir donner une
image et c'est là que ça devient
intéressant le format raw et très gros
puisqu'il ya beaucoup d'informations et
la plupart du temps sur beaucoup de
caméras il y à un traitement qui est
fait une compression pour avoir un
fichier plus légers tino photo d'iphone
on en prendrait quelques dunes et la
mémoire serait plein très très vite en
photo il ya le rô le brut et le jpeg
l'information compressé traité en vidéo
c'est pareil le fichier va être
compressé pour prendre moins de place et
surtout pour être plus facile à lire et
durant cette compression et bien il ya
des informations qui se perdent
notamment sur la plupart des codecs h
264 ou h 264
on est obligé de faire des moyennes de
valeur de couleurs de valeur de lumière
et ça donne lieu à une dégradation
forcément de l'image le progrès c'est
aussi un format compressé mais moins
compressé il est en quête de 2 10 bits
non là aussi on va avoir plus de
variations de couleurs et de variations
de lumière on va avoir probablement une
meilleure plage dynamique également et
qui dit fichiers - compressé 10 fichiers
plus gros également et là ça va poser
peut-être problème c'est pour ça que
notamment sur l'iphone 13 pro on peut
avoir le forez en 4k uniquement à partir
des modèles qui forment 250 gigas de
stockage parce que forcément si ça fait
moins bien le truc qu'on filme de
minutes et s'est plaint et c'est là que
dans la vidéo la plupart des gens n'ont
pas compris c'est dire qu'ils sont
limités à quatre cas 60 images par
seconde doit être très bien on le fait
depuis super longtemps mais on ne fait
pas en prothèses sur un téléphone pour
vous donner un ordre d'idée la seule
caméra à peu près abordable on va dire
dans l'est dans les 1000 2000 euros qui
fait du progrès en interne actuellement
c'est la black magic pockets sinon si on
veut du prez s'est de suite des caméras
à 4,5 euros voire encore plus donc c'est
un codec qui jusqu'ici hormis sur la
black magic était réservé à des grosses
caméras là on le retrouve sur un
téléphone ça veut dire qu'on va pouvoir
aussi est talonné de faim plus fine on
va avoir des réglages qui vont être
beaucoup plus précis et qu'on va pouvoir
retravailler l'image aussi en post
production de manière bien plus
optimisée qu'avec un codec type e âge
265 ou h 264
même principe pour les 60 images par
seconde là aussi c'est très bizarre
parce que le nombre d'image par seconde
ça a un lien avec les ralentis tout
simplement si on veut faire du 120
images par seconde c'est pas pour filmer
à vitesse réelle c'est pour ralentir ça
n'a aucun sens 60 images par seconde
c'est un petit ralenti mais ça reste un
ralenti donc se dire ma caméra elle fait
du 240 images par seconde où je sais pas
combien c'est aussi curieux dans la
mesure où si c'est pas pour faire des
ralentis quoi ça va servir tout
simplement dès qu'on parle d'un
téléphone apple ou android parce qu'il
ya des pros et des contres dans les deux
camps c'est qui est ce qui va avoir les
specs ce n'est plus ouf et j'ai envie de
dire à quoi ça sert parce que même sur
un iphone 13 pro ça va servir vraiment à
très peu de gens des gens qui font du
film uniquement à l'iphone parce que
c'est un concept parce que c'est un
challenge mais personne ne va filmer ces
tic toc ou ses stores y installant
prores en 4k 60 ça c'est évident ça
n'aurait aucun sens mais le fait de se
dire un téléphone est bon parce qu'il
fait de la bic a dites vous bien que
l'habit cas c'est une chose mais le
codec qui va servir à encoder l'image
c'est tout aussi important il serait que
le pro reste dans la keynote apple c'est
quelque chose qui je pense est passée
relativement inaperçue puisque peu utile
pour la plupart des gens qui vont filmer
avec un smartphone mais là où ça devient
vachement intéressant c'est qu'apple a
montré qu'on pouvait dans un smartphone
intègre et de l'enregistrement prores
cadre de 10 bits interne chose que nos
boîtiers hybride ne font pas à ce jour
est ce que je me dis moi et mon petit
pari là que je fais tout de suite là
c'est que ça va faire bouger les choses
si un téléphone est capable de le faire
pourquoi est-ce que 1 à 7 et 3 serait
pas le capable de le faire pourquoi
est-ce qu'un scanner 5 sera pas capable
de le faire pourquoi un z ci serait pas
capable de le faire en interne pour le
moment on peut le faire avec des
enregistreurs en externe mais on peut
pas le faire en interne il ya fort à
parier que un des enjeux de la suite de
l'évolution de nos boîtiers hybride ça
va être les codecs interne le prores en
interne pour moi c'est quelque chose qui
va arriver dans les mois années à venir
c'est quelque chose qui va se
démocratiser et je pense qu'apple n'y
sera pas pour rien avec le fait d'avoir
promu ce codec dans son smartphone comme
étant une fonctionnalité professionnels
et pour finir il reste la grande grande
grande interrogation que je me pose et
que je comprends pas vraiment je n'ai
pas la réponse si vous l'avez donné la
mois dans les commentaires parce que
voilà pourquoi les gens qui ont une
marque de téléphone ou un système
d'exploitation de téléphone insultes
ceux qui en ont un différend pourquoi
les utilisateurs android traite les
utilisateurs apple de pigeons pourquoi
les utilisateurs à peu le traite je ne
sais pas de quoi des utilisateurs
android qu'est ce que ça peut en
fait de la marque du téléphone de
quelqu'un qu'on ne connaît pas sur les
réseaux sociaux et au delà ça même quand
il ya des gens qui mettent dans les
commentaires ouais moi j'ai telle marque
de téléphone et c'est vachement mieux ok
cool ben c'est bien enfin je suis
content pour toi si ton téléphone te
convient et c'est un peu comme les
caméras c'est à dire trouver la caméra
ou le smartphone qui vous convient
éclatez vous avec et ici il ya des gens
qui utilisent un autre matériel et qui
s'éclate avec tant mieux pour eux et si
vous vous éclatez n'hésitez pas à mettre
le traditionnel coup de blaster sur le
pouce en l'air qui se situe juste en
dessous cette vidéo vous pouvez
également vous abonner si c'est pas déjà
fait aller voir une des vidéos qui
s'affiche ici pour continuer un petit
peu d'apprendre des choses sur la vidéo
et moi je vous dis d annie à très
bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo ciao